est ce que vous saviez que quand deux
personnes du sexe opposé discutent
ensemble il ya en général un mensonge
tout les trois interactions salue
aujourd'hui on est mercredi le jour des
astuces et je vous donne des astuces sur
les signes du mensonge comment détecter
un menteur
c'est la suite de la vidéo 90 sur 366
que j'avais déjà fait sur ce sujet là où
l'on avait parlé du regard de la
direction des yeux et le fait de faire
raconter l'histoire à l'endroit ou à
l'envers 5 astuces supplémentaires pour
savoir que la personne ment s'il ya bien
un signe qui ne trompe pas c'est la
distance que peut prendre la personne
avec les faits difficile à comprendre
dit comme ça mais très facile à
comprendre si je vous parle de bill
clinton à l'époque de la sphère monica
levinsky il avait déclaré je n'ai pas eu
de relation avec cette femme
c'est clairement une prise de distance
au lieu de dire avec cette femme il
aurait dû dire je n'ai pas eu de
relation avec monica lewinsky mais le
fait de simplement la globaliser dans un
groupe avec cette femme est un signe
typique du mensonge ces signes doivent
être cumulés entre eux pour avoir la
preuve formelle ou le sentiment formelle
que l'autre ment il peut y en avoir un
ou deux dans une discussion de vérité
mais quand ils sont trop nombreux à
paraître alors là il ya plus de doute
un autre signe c'est la personne qui
répètent systématiquement la question ce
n'est pas parce que la malentendu ce
n'est pas pour préciser votre question
c'est simplement pour gagner du temps un
menteur peux pas répondre spontanément à
la vitesse normale d'une conversation
normale
il doit gagner quelques précieuses
secondes pour préparer son argumentaire
pour préparer son mensonge dans une
conversation normale ça peut arriver
qu'on met beaucoup de temps à répondre
parce qu'on a vraiment besoin d'une
réflexion derrière ça pour se rappeler
un souvenir ou pour avoir un avis
concret construit un mentor à peu près
toujours le même delta de réponse c'est
à dire pas spontanée pas immédiat mais
pas très loin non plus troisième signe
du mensonge le trop de détails inutiles
à ne pas confondre avec les bavards qui
souvent raconte une histoire dans
l'histoire dans l'histoire dans
l'histoire pour revenir au point de
départ mais le menteur lui pour
crédibiliser le fait que l'histoire où
son mensonge est vraiment eu lieu d'en
rajouter plein de détails précis trop
précis trop nombreux beaucoup trop
nombreux qu'on parle c'est qu'on a
toujours un but quelque chose à dire
le menteur lui donne plein de détails
pour donner plein de matières à son
histoire qui sort de nulle part
son premier but c'est de la rendre
crédible avant d'avoir quelque chose de
réel à dire quatrième point c'est
l'utilisation répétée est quasi
systématique des phrases restrictives
les phrases et les expressions
restrictive semaine plus tôt en début de
phrase comme pour dire vrai ou pour te
dire la vérité ou pour être très franc
avec toi ou vraiment pour être honnête
ou je te jure que elles servent à
appuyer la véracité d'un propos alors
que vous n'avez pas encore tenu ce
propos mais vous admettez que
potentiellement la personne pourrait en
douter
naturellement on utilise des phrases
restrictive quand il nous arrivait 1
vraiment fou une histoire insolite on se
dit personne va me croire mais quand ces
phrases là sont utilisés quasi
systématiquement pour des choses très
banal alors attention
vous pouvez avoir un doute et le
cinquième point c'est une analyse que
vous pouvez faire très simplement très
facilement c'est la cohérence entre les
versions et la cohérence direct tout la
personne va raconter une histoire plus
vous allez pouvoir voir des différences
entre les versions
ça c'est le premier point c'est très
facile à voir mais vous pouvez aussi
avoir l'esprit critique sur la cohérence
direct soit entre l'histoire et qui est
la personne à titre d'exemple les
réactions que dit avoir eu la personne
dans l'histoire qu'elle vous raconte est
ce qu'elles sont assez crédible est-ce
qu'elles correspondent à ce que vous
connaissez de cette personne est ce que
vous l'avez déjà vu réagir comme ça est
ce que vous l'imaginez comme ça bien
souvent quand c'est un mensonge non
parce que c'est trop ou pas assez ou
trop différent de la personne idem pour
la cohérence direct de l'histoire
parfois dans l'histoire qu'on vous
raconte
il ya une vraie grosse incohérence une
vraie incohérence de logique entre le
début de l'action ce qui s'est passé la
fin de l'action c'est quelque chose que
vous n'auriez pas fait comme ça que
personne n'aurait fait comme ça ça peut
être aussi de la cohérence temporel les
dates et les lieux ne peuvent pas
correspondre à tout ce qui a été raconté
après ça vous de voir où vous décidez de
piéger la personne en lui demandant des
précisions sur les points incohérent ou
vous laisser poulet et vous essayé
d'associer sa d'autres signes du
mensonge pour déterminer si c'est un
mensonge ou pas encore une fois rappelez
vous il faut prendre en compte tout le
contexte et voir s'il ya plusieurs
signes qui vous permettent de déduire
que c'est un mensonge c'est la deuxième
vidéo sur le sujet j'aimerais vous en
faire une troisième qui parlerait plus
du langage corporel liés aux mensonges
avec les lapsus emblématique les
illustrant si vous êtes plutôt chaud
pour qu'on aborde ce sujet vous me le
dites dans les commentaires et on verra
je le passerai peut-être en master
classes soit avant mi juillet soit début
septembre
seulement si ça vous branche vendredi je
vais mentaliser l'un ou l'une d'entre
vous on l'a déjà fait dans deux vidéos
précédentes
j'appelle l'un d'entre vous par skype et
j'essaye de le mentaliser je vais
tourner cette vidéo demain donc
aujourd'hui à 17 heures sur mon facebook
au moment où sur cette vidéo je vais
créer un poste pour que vous puissiez
participer ou essayer de participer il
suffira de cliquer de mettre un
commentaire de dans tout ça donc sur la
fanpage sur facebook vous avez le lien
dans le descriptif
j'espère que cette vidéo vous a plu je
vous prépare un truc aussi pour la
semaine prochaine pour fêter les 30
millions vient de les passer avant de
partir n'oubliez pas de laisser un
sincère et sympathique pouce en l'air et
de vous abonner à la chaîne en cliquant
sur le logo ou sur sa bonne et juste en
dessous puisque le mental dogues c'est
une vidéo par jour pendant un an depuis
le 1er janvier donc rendez vous demain à
17 heures ciao